voici maintenant le jury les membres du
jury du festival cette année ont accepté
d'apparaître à visage découvert pour que
les cinéastes qui ne serait pas
récompensé sacha qui s'en prendre
physiquement
voici donc deux pour commencer l'auteur
de bandes dessinées cinéaste français
enki bilal perdre
[Applaudissements]
la réalisatrice et scénariste américaine
kelly reichardt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le réalisateur et producteur grec yorgos
lanthimos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la réalisatrice et scénariste italienne
ali gerba coeur
[Musique]
le réalisateur français robin campillo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la réalisatrice et actrice burkinabé
maimouna n'diaye
[Applaudissements]
réalisateur et scénariste polonais pawel
pawlikowski
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'actrice américaine elle fanning
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dur est maintenant complet afin si
manque le président première prise de
contact entre eux c'est assez émouvant
d'imaginer tout ce créateur ses talents
ses génies de tous les pays du monde
de quoi parlent-ils qu'est-ce qui se
disent selon est incroyable et parfois
on est déçu parce qu'en fait ils sont
comme nous voit on parle quoi météo
début foot la famille ça va donc ne
rêvons pas pas de complexe